We're on problem 141.
On Jane's credit card account,
the average daily balance for
a 30 day billing cycle-- when I
see these long paragraphs it
starts to give you a headache--
the average daily
balance for a 30 day billing
cycle is the average of the
daily balances at the end
of each of the 30 days.
OK, so they take the average
balance of each of the days
and then they average it.
OK.
At the beginning of a certain
30 day billing cycle, Jane's
credit card account had
a balance of $600.
At the beginning.
What problem is this?
141.
So at the beginning, she
had a balance of $600.
Fair enough.
Jane made a payment of
$300 on the account
during the billing cycle.
So this is the beginning of the
month, and then at some
point-- this is 30 days later--
at some point she made
a $300 payment.
Fair enough.
Continuing.
If no other amounts were added
or subtracted from the account
during the billing cycle, what
was the average daily balance
on Jane's account for
the billing cycle?
OK, so I think I'm visualizing
this right.
If we say that this is days,
where this is day 0
and this is day 30.
So essentially, at the end of
every day, so at the end of
day 1-- so at the beginning of a
certain billing cycle Jane's
credit card account had
a balance of $600.
So we don't know.
She might have paid
it on day 1.
So I'm not going to put
any labels here.
But she starts at 600.
And that's her balance until on
some day she pays off half
of it, and her balance
goes down like that.
So the question is, what
is the average?
So it's going to be $600 times a
certain number of days, plus
$300 times a certain number
of days, divided by 30.
So let me write that down.
The average is going to be equal
to $600 times however
many days she carried the $600
balance plus $300 times
however many days she kept
the $300 balance.
And that's going to
be 30 minus x.
If she paid after 15 days, she
would have had a $600 balance
for 15 days and then she would
have had the $300 for the
remainder of the days.
If she paid after one day, then
you would have the $300
balance for 29 days.
And all of that divided by 30.
That's the average.
And I try to do that from the
get-go, because I just want to
get my algebraic brain around
the problem so it
becomes less abstract.
So statement number one.
Let me keep that
in the screen.
Statement number one tells us
Jane's payment cycle was
credited on the 21st day
of the billing cycle.
So that means she had a $600--
that x in this example-- that
she had a $600 balance
for 20 days.
And then on the 21st day
her balance would
have gone to $300.
So the average is going to be
equal to $600-- she had a $600
balance for the first 20 days.
Times 20 plus 300 times
the remainder days.
So 300 for 10 days.
And that's all divided by
the number of days.
So statement one, alone, is
enough to figure out her
average balance for the month.
Statement two.
The average daily balance
through the 25th day of the
billing cycle was $540.
This is interesting.
So $540 is the average
through the 25th day.
So if we average the first 25
days-- so her balance was $600
for x days, plus $300
for the remainder.
Only the first 25 days.
So it's x minus 25.
So you can actually take this
equation and solve for x.
It's actually a linear
equation.
And I'm sure this time.
Multiply both sides by
25, you get a number.
And then you can distribute
this out.
Add all the x terms.
Solve for x.
And then once you solve for x,
you can just use this equation
up here to figure out
the average daily
balance for 30 days.
So actually, each of these
statements independently are
sufficient to figure
out this problem.
Actually, it was very critical
that we kind of thought about
in this term from the get-go.
Otherwise this would have been
a very hard problem to get
your hand around.
But it's interesting.
I, strangely, really
like that problem.
Anyway, next problem.
142.
If x is an integer, they're
asking is 9 to the x plus 9 to
the minus x equal to b?
Who knows?
Problem one says 3 to the x plus
3 to the minus x is equal
to the square root
of b plus 2.
So right from the get-go I don't
see-- I mean there's 3's
there's 9's, there seems to
be some relationship.
Let's square both sides of this
equation, see if it can
reduce to something that's
useful here.
So the right hand
side is easy.
The left hand side, if you
square it you get 3 to the 2x.
And then you get plus
2 times these
multiplied by each other.
3 to the x, 3 to the minus x
plus 3 to the minus 2x is
equal to b plus 2.
I just squared both sides.
3 to the x times 3 to
the minus x, that
just equals 1, right?
You could add the exponents,
that's equal to 3 to the 0.
That equals 1.
Or you could view that as 3 to
the x divided by 3 to the x.
Either way, that equals 1.
Then you're left with 2 on both
sides of the equation.
So you can get rid of that.
So then we're left with 3 to the
2x plus 3 to the minus 2x
is equal to b.
But then we could
rewrite this.
Think about this.
3 to the 2x, that's the same
thing as 3 squared to the x.
And this is the same thing as
3 to the minus 2 to the x is
equal to b.
And I think now bells are
ringing in your head.
3 squared, that's the same thing
as 9 to the x plus-- I
should do 3 squared
to the minus x.
That's easier.
Plus 9 to the minus
x is equal to b.
So statement number one actually
reduced to what we
were trying to prove.
So statement number one, at
least alone, is sufficient.
Let's see what statement
number two gets us.
Statement number two says x is
greater than 0 is equal to b.
Let's see.
The original was 9 to the
x plus 9 to the minus
x is equal to b.
So they're now saying that
b is equal to 0.
So how does that help us?
If b is equal to 0-- let's
subtract 9 to the minus x from
both sides.
You get 9 to the x is equal
to minus 9 to the minus x.
Now let me multiply both sides
by negative 9 to the x.
I just want to make this--
minus 9 to the x times
minus 9 to the x.
I'm just trying to
simplify it.
So what do you have here?
The minus sign, minus
9 to the 2x, right?
Just add the exponents.
Is equal to-- a minus times a
minus is a positive-- and then
a minus x and a positive x.
Add them together, you get 0.
So 9 and 0 is 1.
That simplifies to minus 9
to the 2x is equal to 1.
So can this ever be true?
Let me think about that.
The only way something that's
non 1 or non negative 1, the
only way that when you raise it
to a power you can get a 1
is if you raise it
to a 0th power.
So this is only true
if x is equal to 0.
But they tell us that
x is greater than 0.
So, actually, this is
an interesting case.
Using the information they
gave us in problem number
two-- I just want to make sure
I'm not missing something.
Statement one was sufficient.
Can we prove--
well, we don't have
enough information
to prove the statement.
We have enough information to
disprove the statement but not
to prove it.
So I'm going to stick with a.
I was going to say that we can
say whether the statement is
true or false, but we definitely
don't have enough
information with just statement
b to prove-- so they
want to know, right.
You have to be able to prove
the statement is true.
Statement two actually proves
that it is false.
It doesn't prove
that it's true.
It answers the question
but says no.
So statement one, alone, is
sufficient to say that that
statement is true.
And I'll continue in
the next video.